-Here with the TV debut of his new song, "Evangeline,"
please welcome Stephen Sanchez!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Let me give it all ♪
♪ I'll give you all this to make you mine ♪
♪ And if you need a minute ♪
♪ Honey, I'll give you all my time ♪
♪ All the time ♪
♪ Do you need the Sandman? ♪
♪ Or a phone call to Mr. Jones? ♪
♪ Ohh ♪
♪ Put your dreams to sleep ♪
♪ With rattling bones ♪
♪ So don't go to sleep ♪
♪ Don't rest your head ♪
♪ I'll be the pillow ♪
♪ And I'll be the bed ♪
♪ Holding your dreams ♪
♪ As you lie to rest ♪
♪ Evangeline ♪
♪ Don't go to sleep ♪
♪ Don't rest your head ♪
♪ I'll be the pillow ♪
♪ And I'll be the bed ♪
♪ Holding your dreams ♪
♪ As you lie to rest ♪
♪ Evangeline ♪
♪ Anybody call the doctor? ♪
♪ I'm a thousand degrees in love ♪
♪ Ohh ♪
♪ And I'm sick of all the guessing ♪
♪ Between the two of us ♪
♪♪
♪ You're my angel in the doorway ♪
♪ I couldn't bear to lose you ♪
♪ And if you're so in love ♪
[ Singing indistinctly ]
♪ So don't go to sleep ♪
♪ Don't rest your head ♪
♪ I'll be the pillow ♪
♪ And I'll be the bed ♪
♪ Holding your dreams ♪
♪ As you lie to rest ♪
♪ Evangeline ♪
♪ Don't go to sleep ♪
♪ Don't rest your head ♪
♪ I'll be the pillow ♪
♪ And I'll be the bed ♪
♪ Holding your dreams ♪
♪ As you lie to rest ♪
♪ Evangeline ♪
♪♪
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]